Hello, I'm steez Carp
Today, it's not Japanese but English sound
About studying English
Specifically, I would like to say my own way of thinking about what is difficult for Japanese to
study English,
but by all means
later.  Japanese people
I would love to hear your opinion about what is the biggest problem with the person studying English from my own experience,
but in my opinion, of course, I'm no longer Japanese.
However, I have never studied English as a foreigner, so I have no experience of it, but I have the experience of studying a language that is completely different from English, which is Japanese
.
I don't know if it's wrong at all, but
I'll lift my way of thinking.
First of all, but I definitely want to hear your opinions.
First of all,
when studying English, or  What I have
to think about when studying Japanese is
that different words are
a place in strategy, I'm talking about Ieya, but almost any
word
conveys the same meaning.
You can tell it, right? It's a
big
deal, but strategically, all the words are the
same. You can get along with the same meaning.
It's different for each
language to convey the meaning, so when I study the next new foreign language, I don't often say that it's different in various details
.
And one more thing, this is also a matter of attitude,
but I always want to talk about what I can talk to Mu-
cho.  I can't do it, I forgot it, I
don't know how it blooms, and when that happens, it's very +0 top
management
.
What's the difference between the
two? First of all, the one is far away, isn't it?
It won't be there, it's going
up, it's going up, it's going up, it's going from anyone,
it's okay
.  It takes a tremendous amount of time to be able to do that. No matter how much you look at the explanation,
it
won't be a week
.  No. 1 Heavy Rain
Idol Fusion Deigo Hatsuko Badge Heavy Rain It's okay to understand that,
it takes time for the brain to get used to
it.
In
the case of English, it's the first time that ion air
ime's love edition Ghan i heading forcible
ion
It's a quick September
in that area.  After understanding, there is no such thing as whether it can be used correctly
. In the opposite case of mine, I will go when I study Japanese.
It takes a tremendous amount of time. No
matter how many times I look at the explanation, I don't understand
. That's why I can erase it. The
other thing is that the city is very different
.
Hane
omar owners come behind
me What I think to everyone
English version icems And
many Japanese people speak English to the route
today is a signal day i swing
That's a mistake.
It's still from the head in Japan. When you first study, you need to understand this first. When you
read or listen, the eye-fitting Taoist starts.
You
have to know Mori. It takes time
to be able to speak so naturally,
but you have to understand that
you have at least possession.  Well, it's not just that the company opens
this asa ni Zu Bock Ai Smoke
Forcible 2 and I go to the store In
the case of English, it's an iron forcible, so whichever Japanese comes first is behind
Not only that, but in the case of English,
eh r 2
woman money iaea is it works web campaign
Japan is
for tears to set up money, what is it, what is it,
what is different in English, even though it's
week rs ran
ah ah  Ah ah dog e 2 to
Boober's house alea Alea
House goes to the beginning I think about the sequence of the words,
but it takes time to get used to
it, and I think it's difficult in English is that thin
party bar proposition endear chain  Fitting House
Farm House Art
Howes That's
right, but it's not a big deal if you make a mistake
. I understand your dreams.
Zokon Carpecorn a
No, it's just a matter of time, so don't worry too much. I
think it's hard to understand even if you look at the explanation
,
so it doesn't affect the meaning so much.
I don't really need Kondo because there are so many words that
don't exist.
I don't know the one-drop box file box on the table of the election pro.
With the sound of Tea Heart Rose s
I'm web
vocabulary It's important to read a lot-
and gradually after 2 English In the case of the cabin, the virus and boys collection
Nanban Burger Bar is
like that
.  It's
easy to understand the relationship between words, but I
wonder if it's the same in English. Aigo isn't hearing English from Spain
.  Please
give us your opinion and your own experience
.